hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation titled covet 19
point of care diagnostics the importance
of timing and rna levels this webinar is
part of the 2021 microbiology virtual
week and i'm susie valdez of lab roots
and i will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
use that education credits tab located
at the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
present today's speaker dr daniel
griffin he is the chief of the division
of infectious disease a pro-health new
york an optum company and a senior
fellow for infectious disease with uhd
research and development and finally the
clinical instructor of medicine at
columbia university for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top right hand
corner of your screen dr griffin welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
all right well thank you for that kind
introduction
um and yeah definitely people take
advantage as we go along and think about
what questions you might have this is
sort of your opportunity to
hopefully
ask me lots of hard questions try to
stump me
but yeah just to give people a little
bit of background
we're going to be talking a lot about
the covid 19 care diagnostics what are
the different tests to
determine whether or not someone has or
had covid19
and let me let me jump right from my
slide here into what what are the
objectives what am i hoping at the end
of this we'll say about 45 minutes of me
talking and about 15 minutes of people
hopefully asking those hard questions
what are people going to walk away with
so one and i think this is really key
with covet 19
timing matters so
i'm going to be spending a lot of time
going through the the viral kinetics
and what what impact that has on which
tests are appropriate when which tests
will be positive when which tests will
be negative when
i want to go through what are all those
different tests what are what are our
available testing options
and then i think this is really critical
when you get a result whether it's
positive whether it's negative
what's the predictive value what's the
likelihood that that result that you
just got is accurate is is telling you
what you want that to tell you
um and i'll just give people a little
bit maybe more background
you know those those are my titles um
but we've really done a lot in the i'm
going to say in the testing space i feel
like i'm working for a company which yes
sometimes i am um not only am i a
clinician so not only am i applying
these different tests um at the point of
care when i see a patient um in the
office when i see a patient in the
hospital when i see a patient after that
when i'm um
advising and consulting for our urgent
care or primary care physicians
but we also
have a large program
and i'm the sort of clinician expert for
um where we do screening programs for a
lot of uh
movie and television productions so
we've run programs for lionsgate netflix
amazon prime
a lot of other businesses that really
needed to get back to work
that were losing a lot of money trying
to figure out how can you test
the nhl bubble i was actually
involved in that so i'm going to talk
about a lot of different scenarios um
how do we get schools open how do we get
businesses open and then what do we do
when we've got a patient sitting in
front of us
now this abstract is very wordy and i
think you can go
somewhere and read through all this but
let me just break it down into bullet
points what are we going to be talking
about today
so one of the first things i'm going to
try to reinforce as we go forward
is that critical in control of this
pandemic is the ability to rapidly
identify infectious individuals
prior to their ability to infect others
right
it's no use and it was no use during um
the early days of the pandemic when we
would call someone four days after they
got the test
to tell them that the test is positive
once they probably had already been out
and about and infecting others i'm going
to talk about
how critical timing and resulting delays
is
and i'm going to be talking a bit about
this distinction between an infectious
individual
and someone that still tests positive
this ties directly into the second point
that we're going to spend a lot of time
on
many of the diagnostic tests are
expensive
and periodically particularly when we
get surges can suffer from significant
resulting delays
and then
this is going to tie in as well
and we're going to talk a lot about this
concept of cycle threshold ct values
levels of rna
and the the concept the important
concept
that with low levels of rna which are
going to correlate with low levels of
the antigens of the proteins that are
being picked up we're going to end up
with negative antigen test so patients
with low levels of rna and negative
antigen tests
as we're going to look through the
kinetics here they appear to be at very
low risk for spread of disease i'm going
to talk about why it's actually not only
okay
but maybe appropriate
to
not pick those people up right away and
still
have a second test looking at that so
all right
i like to say with covid
timing matters timing is really critical
and so i'm not going to have a lot of
slides today but what i am going to do
is i'm going to focus on several slides
that really have the graphics that go
through the stages of the disease
and we're going to talk about the
different levels of the virus we're
going to talk about different levels of
the antigens
the timing of infectiousness so
there are several things that we now
really i think have good evidence to
talk about
as far as the the early stages and
testing so one
is that exposure point
and we're going to move on to a graphic
here shortly where we look at
what is the time from when a person is
exposed
to when they go ahead and actually start
testing positive start being contagious
start having symptoms
and don't worry i'm going to talk about
does the delta variant change that
i think they they we just happily call
it the delta because that is you know
for change
then i'm going to talk about when you go
from exposure to the detectable viral
replication period
we're going to talk a little bit about
where that ties in when do people first
start having symptoms relative to these
events and then
and i think this is really critical the
early inflammatory phase when people end
up in the hospital
and i'm going to talk a little bit about
maybe there's a different question we're
asking um during that time
i won't spend quite um as much or really
much time at all talking about that sort
of late secondary infection phase or
that late inflammatory or even the
multi-system inflammatory phase today
and i will not spend too much time
talking on the tail when we start to see
the the past the post-acute sequelae of
covid the long covered
but
perhaps in another talk
all right so this is really the meat
of what i'm going to be talking talking
about today
in a sense this is this is the money
slide if you could just take one slide
um and uh and remember it burn it into
your memory i'm going to say this is the
slide because we're going to we're going
to look at this slide and i have to say
this slide was actually produced
initially early on in the pandemic
and it's too large degree
stood the test of time
so
i i don't give you the key so i'm going
to walk through the key with you
together so what is this t sub e this is
as i talked about this is the time of
exposure right so prior to this is that
whole period when hopefully people are
rushing out getting their vaccines
doing all the pre-exposure things they
can do to get themselves in good shape
should that exposure actually happen
right so we let our guard down we end up
in a situation perhaps it's indoors
perhaps there's no mask on perhaps the
ventilation is is not so great
that
10 to 15 minutes or longer cumulative
exposure
the person is is talking you know
imagine that talking breathing coughing
sneezing
generating those infectious exposures
and then we realized that that happened
now
i often get this you know person that
happens i remember my mom you know i got
a test the next day it was negative i
missed the bullet it's all good of
course it's negative the next day
because there is a period of time an
incubation period
from that time of exposure
to the time that a person actually
starts having
symptoms so so technically right in our
common usage the incubation period is
the time from exposure to the time
that we have disease right to the time
someone has symptoms but i think with
the amount of testing there's also sort
of a secondary phenomenon this
incubation period when they might
actually during that incubation period
develop a
time to detectable viral replication and
that's that's where we're going to be
going and talking about today
and i'm going to on the next slide don't
worry we're going to throw in the delta
variant but let's let's start off what
did we learn over the last year well we
learned that that incubation period from
time of exposure
to when a person might start having
symptoms so t sub s the time of symptom
onset um that window that incubation
period is 2
to 14 days
and what i want everyone to focus on
here
are is or i should say this purple this
purple line
and then this pcr
detection limit and this infectious
level
so what happens over time and we talk a
little bit about our screening
approaches
there is a very slow period of time the
virus is replicating
if a person is going to end up
symptomatic or infected but the viral
replication is at such a low level it is
below
any of our current
levels of detection
then at a certain point that viral
replication really takes off really
exponentially
and i i can imagine this as
like a slide in the playground right the
steep steps that you go up and then
you're going to go up down a more slow
slope on the other side but there is a
period of time when that viral
replication increases
to a point where we can actually start
to detect it with our pcr tests right so
this is the traditional that beautiful
test where a q-tip initially was plunged
deep into the darkness a blind
maneuver
it was rotated it was pulled back out
and sent off for our pcr testing we
still do a lot of that um we can talk a
little bit about does it really need to
be that deep um isopharyngeal
middle turbinate swab or can it be
anterior narys
but there is a window here
when the pcr will pick it up before a
person becomes infectious
this has been critical to all our
screening programs for a lot of say the
movie entertainment industry
what we've been doing and i'm going to
go through some some calculators some
online tools
but what we've been doing at great
expense to the management of these
studios is having everyone at the end of
the work day so in a sense before the
next work day the evening before the
next work day getting everyone pcr
tested
if they come back positive we're picking
them up before they go to the workplace
and become infectious
this infectious level as i'm going to
talk a little bit this is when you start
having so much virus that the antigen
becomes detectable by these rapid tests
so what we've successfully done now for
it's over a year is catch people ahead
of time when they still have a pcr
detectable level but have not reached an
infectious level
if we get a positive test the next
morning we might confirm this
or if the story is good we're good to go
but this is this critical window but i
want to say this window is small and
we're going to talk about how delta has
impacted
the size of that window
this initially the ancestral uh variants
that we were seeing um so wuhan
beta gamma this was actually
many many hours maybe a day
to go from this period here where we can
first detect viral replication to the
part where we get infectious
we then have a period of time right
here's our little window and now for
about two days right so we're going to
add that up front pcr but now we have
about two days when a person on average
is infectious before they start having
symptoms and this has been critical in a
lot of our testing and screening
programs this is not influenza this is
not sars sars1
this is a virus where a chunk of the
transmission occurs either in the
pre-symptomatic or in some cases the
asymptomatic individual
so you can see from this period of time
from the
vertical dotted vertical dashed red line
out to the solid red line we have a
period of pre-symptomatic where a person
is going to test positive both by
our rapid antigen tests that correlate
very well with infectious levels
they're also going to test positive with
pcr
they are going to continue to test
positive
by both modalities for the next three to
four to five days
then what is going to happen
is the level of the viral rna which
correlates with antigen so really the
antigen level is going to drop
the virus is going to drop below an
infectious level it's also going to drop
below a level where our antigen tests
are going to continue to be positive
so i want to really point out this is
really this level here the pcr test is
going to continue out
we have descriptions of people 100 days
out still testing positive
but certainly people continue to test
pcr positive 10 days 20 days where that
antigen positivity that level of
infectiousness is really a much more
narrow window
all right um before i move to delta um i
just want to point out when we see
people in the hospital right so we have
people who we're either seeing and
sending to the hospital or we're seeing
they are usually no longer in this early
viral replication period they're no
longer in the sort of the viral symptom
phase these are individuals that are
starting to have that early inflammatory
phase some of us early on called this
the cytokine storm other people called
it the pulmonary phase we've kind of
i guess agreed to agree on the early
inflammatory phase which captures a lot
of this
this is when the level of the virus is
starting to drop
um that may actually be to the point
where we're no longer picking it up with
the antigen
test
this is where the pcr i'm going to sort
of say is the right test to go with
think about timing when we're picking
different tests
so all right now
this is great but dr griffin what about
the delta variant does that change
things are there different tests are
there different kinetics and i'm going
to go ahead and say it seems like there
is
the delta variant seems to be spreading
twice as fast
as the other variants right it has
quickly competed i mean i say now when
you get a
cova test in the united states when you
get a sars kobe to test the united
states it's a delta test at this point
we'll see if any other variants can
out-compete delta and
how has it done it how is it twice as
fast well we don't know all of the
science here but one thing we do know is
that incubation period seems to be
impacted
before
on on average the median time
from exposure to a positive test was
seven to eight days
it now appears that that is about four
days so about twice as quick
we also
suspect that this upslope is shorter
it looks like that first test when you
get it back you have much higher levels
so there's a steeper slope there is a
shift to the left so let's let's shift
and see what that now looks like this
does actually change things so that does
the delta does the delta variant change
things i'm going to suggest that the
data we have suggests that we need to
slightly redo
our our flowchart our diagram our
thinking
what we're seeing now
is that time from exposure out to about
four days and when the person is testing
positive at four days that upslope is
very quick now we're actually i think
making that window between a positive
pcr and a positive antigen test now just
a matter of hours right we still haven't
seen failures yet in our screening
programs
and a lot of programs have now added
sort of same early morning antigen tests
so that you don't you know miss someone
from the day before i say a
test is great but a test does not
predict the future
but this is a big shift that we're
seeing with the delta variant
that pcr quick detection is is not maybe
as important as it used to be
that pcr that's 72 hours
in the past
is becoming less reliable because that
person can very quickly go
to a point where they have a
more than an infectious level of virus
now we don't know about the other side
we don't know if this changes the slope
on the other side if a person is
vaccinated right we have nice
kinetics out of singapore and a few
other studies
showing that the the period of
infectiousness looks like it is
truncated
with um with vaccine so we may have a
rapid rise in viral rna it may not even
all be
effective
virus because about 50 of those people
are not making enough nuclear capsid or
viral proteins to be picked up with our
antigen tests so two things change this
the delta variant changes the kinetics
here
but vaccines also change the kinetics
here on the on the tail end here
all right so let's let's go to what are
our different tests let's let's apply
this this knowledge now that we have it
there's really two main types of tests
that we're using
we're using direct virus detection
you're sort of asking that question in
in your patient or your patient wants to
know the answer to the question do i
have it now
and the second um is going to be an area
that i'm not going to talk quite as much
about but it really is
did i have it before right so serology
tests um i think actually in all honesty
people are asking am i going to get it
in the future a lot of times when
they're requesting that serology test
they're asking the question of
is there is there some protection i have
is it waning and we won't go there today
but i'm sure other talk other speakers
will talk about that
but let's really focus on this direct
virus testing
either picking up viral nucleic acid
through a nucleic acid amplification
test or antigen testing and most of
those antigen tests are going as after
nuclear capsid which at least for the b
cells is the immunodominant protein it's
the the most produced protein t cells a
little smarter they seem to be targeting
the spike right from the get-go so let's
look at our tests let's look at
i'm going to say sensitivity
just clicked on that i'm going to go to
the next one here all right so
i want to get a little sophistication
here
a lot of times people just ask how
sensitive is this test
the the tests are actually
very very sensitive
all the tests are very very sensitive if
we're asking about um picking up someone
who has infectious levels of virus um
but there's a different sensitivity if
we're just trying to pick up someone who
has a small amount so hopefully people
are kind of getting this as we get to
this part so we're doing our screening
programs we want to pick someone up
who's just starting to have
amplification of the virus in in that
early phase right so we want to pick
them up before they go
to the production studio or the job or
before they get in front of that class
and and teach the
unvaccinated children
a very very sensitive test for picking
up low levels of rna
is going to be our pcr testing right
we're running these out to 40 or more
cycles right the more rna there
the quicker you amplify that up right so
you know if you have millions or
billions of rna copies you only have to
run so many cycles 10 20 cycles and the
machine you know goes off dings we have
we have a result if there's a tiny
amount there we're going to have to run
it you know 39 40 cycles and when we do
that we can pick up someone who only has
about a thousand or less
hundreds of rna copies right so
incredibly sensitive
that's great picking them up front but
also think about our curve that's also
going to be great when they show up in
the hospital they're starting to
decompensate they're starting to require
oxygen they're having trouble breathing
doctor i've been sick for like 12 13
days
i think this is coveted right at that
point they're probably not infectious
anymore they're past that 10 days
so this is where you're going to want
that sensitivity
but what about the person who shows up
in the in the clinic i'm having trouble
having trouble i don't feel well i've
got a fever i've got a headache
and you want to know
is that person not only acutely infected
but are they contagious i mean do we
want someone um going into the workplace
so as you can see as you go through here
as you get to higher rna copy numbers as
you get towards the the peak there
at about a thousand right about a
thousand rna copy number that's going to
be about 36 cycles that you're going to
be running that pcr when you get to an
rna copy number of about 4 000
that's going to be where the abbott id
now is going to pick up an individual
and i'm going to sort of pause here to
talk about you know where where are you
going to want to get that sample
the middle turbinate
that's going to come up a couple cycles
two to three cycles earlier
than that anterior nares right so
you know if you're really looking for
the height of sensitivity
you might think about that again
hospitalized patient
really long into the course i don't want
to miss them i want to know whether or
not this is coveted okay you're doing
that middle turbinate but in general
you're testing people on a regular basis
uh the difference between just a couple
um cycles on the pcr you're still gonna
you're still gonna get a positive test
unless you're talking about someone with
just a few hundred rna copies
then we get to the next level this is
the level where our rapid antigen tests
start to turn positive and this is
actually going to be at a lower level
than even the level at which a person is
infectious so um
we can look here at sort of this this
quick cheat sheet you can
make a screen shot of this this is
actually from one of our one of our
papers where we were talking about
testing strategies for schools and
businesses
at about an rna copy number of only 50
000
the rapid antigen tests are going to
start to turn positive
people look like they're not really
infectious until they're less than 30
until they're in the 20s really when
they have rna copy numbers in the
millions so
people can start be thinking about
when you say a test is sensitive or not
if a person has
millions
of rna copy number if they're in that
two days before that three days after
let me show you in a couple slides here
in that period when the transmission is
occurring i'm going to say that the
rapid
antigen tests are no less sensitive than
the pcr it's in the high 90s their
correlation with transmission and
contact tracing and with viral culture
data is excellent
pcr is going to continue to stay
positive for a long time you're going to
pick up people who had an episode in the
past
you're going to pick up people who are
not infectious
we want to know that in certain settings
in other settings you've got to ask what
is the question because the sensitivity
is relative to the amount of rna it's
relative to timing
if you go ahead and look at all your
pcrs if you look at that person who's
still testing positive 20 days out you
include a bunch of people who are still
pcr positive after day 10 with low
levels of rna the antigen will not pick
those people up and the more of those
people in the sample will skew your
concept of sensitivity so i want people
to think about that
um all right what what do these tests
look like
um
and i think i don't know if people have
actually in our audience have actually
gone to the lab but um it's kind of neat
to go in and see behind the scenes what
exactly is going on
early in the pandemic
here at pro health new york we got a
couple of these
holagic panther
and they're actually we say pcr
but they're a template mediated
amplification they use a luminosity
they're they're actually slightly more
sensitive than pcr no one knows what tma
stands for so we make sure in our
verbage we just say um you know pcr or
equivalent
but these are massive machines
a run will do over a thousand samples
they want to be a little careful about
cross-contamination
the
tma hologic panther pcr equivalent
is going to have a cycle run time about
90 minutes right so you can you know
pretty pretty big throughput in um in
these um going through the whole process
um pcr machines um various forms of
those um but then we also have our
isothermal amplification people may be
familiar with the abbott id now i've got
pictured down here
really very
simple
machine sits there on the counter we
have these scattered throughout
most of our hundred plus urgent cares in
the tri-state area person comes in they
get the swab
there's all sort of cassette process
here
the q-tip goes in
and actually this gives you some sort of
you know it runs for about you know 12
to 15 minutes boy if it comes up after
five or six minutes um you know that
there was
a high amount of rna that was amplified
but then we've also got our antigen
tests
we have bd veritor we have coidel we
have this binax now uh home test and i
do want to talk a little bit about these
as well
because i always get questions like dr
griffin you know
i i want first class testing i want to
sit up in the front of the airplane i
don't want to be sitting back here and
coach with the antigen test i want a
test that's going to be as sensitive as
i can get well hopefully i'm starting to
get across like your sensitivity has a
lot to do with what question are you
asking
really nice recent study where they were
using the the covid cards the bindex now
they had people doing this at home all
right so this isn't even a sophisticated
clinician with proper training these are
people at home unsupervised sticking
q-tips up their nose um five circles on
either side uh putting a couple drops of
fluid on this cards putting in the q-tip
and waiting 15 minutes incredible
sensitivity for picking up people in
those two days prior to symptoms three
days after high 90s actually
the bd veritour
a lot like our pregnancy test right
where a lot of our offices are using
these
bd has also come out with one which will
not only look for sars cov2 not only
allow you to diagnose covet
but also have flu on the same strip so
you do that swab and you're getting your
influenza you're getting your coved test
at the same time
and actually are some quad tests where
they're breaking it down into
influence a influenza b
rsv
and kovit right so
really nice and i think the big thing i
want to throw here is right i talked
about how that huge machine it gets
loaded you wait till you have your
thousand i think it's 1080 samples in a
run um you wait till you have those all
loaded the runtime may be short but
getting it all loaded getting it in
there getting the results back out
and then you start having issues with
throughput during a search
this may be the hologic panther the pcr
the template mediated amplification
testing there may ever be a resulting
delay in there of hours to days
where our rapid tests are going to be
giving us results in 15 minutes i'm
going to talk on this next slide about
why why is
a resulting delay such a critical thing
for us to be talking about
and this is
the covid19 transmission dynamics among
close contacts of indexed patients with
covid19
this is really a great study
it's it's one of many dots in this line
really demonstrating that the vast
majority of transmission occurs in this
narrow window of two days before
and three days after symptom onset so
what we have here is actually the
adjusted risk right so so you've been
exposed to someone who ends up testing
positive for
sars cov2 they have covid you wanna know
what is your risk that you're gonna go
ahead and get it and actually you're
only at increased risk if that exposure
occurred two days before the symptom
onset and three days after so i want
people to be thinking about the
viral kinetics and the pcr testing and
the antigen testing
so individual comes in we're going to
take this individual
and they say you know i'm not feeling
well
i want to get tested we're going to know
ahead of time that this person actually
has coved
we send off that pcr test
they go ahead and
two three days later you get that call
that that pcr test is positive
you call them i love this i use call
them they're at the office they're at
the school they're they're at the
grocery store
and i say i'm calling to let you know
that that pcr test is positive and they
want to know should i should i go home
right now or maybe i should finish out
the uh the teaching day because we can't
get a sub you know here at you know 11
o'clock in the morning
the critical thing here is that if that
person
who came in during this two to five day
window had been given a rapid test 15
minutes later we would have a result
we'd be able to pull them out those
rapid tests during this two days before
three days after high 90s in terms of
sensitivity but what if the person comes
and sees you you know i've been feeling
well i haven't been feeling well for the
last seven days
now that person is probably past that
period where ninety percent of the
transmission occurs
you might do your antigen test at this
point it comes back negative now this is
where you need to be educating the
patient you say you know what you're you
may be past that point of infectiousness
we still recommend that there is this
isolation for we'll say 10 days right
that's what it is in most states some
still at 14.
i'm going to send off a pcr test because
maybe what's going on here is you're
below that level
and then you send off the pcr test and
then you've got to make a judgment based
on your clinical sensitivity your cl
your pre-test probability that we're
about to talk
about and you tell that individual to
isolate while you're waiting for that
but remember during this two days before
three days after
that person if you do a rapid test you
have this opportunity to make the
diagnosis within 15 minutes
pull them out
preventing further spread and further
exposures you also have the ability
immediately
to have them reach out to the people
they've exposed those people can get in
can get tested this has become really
critical as i've talked about with the
change in timing with the delta variant
right
four days from exposure to positivity by
the time you might get a delayed pcr
result and you track down the exposed
individuals you get them tested
with the delta variant they may have
already gotten to an infectious level
and you may have a next cycle you may be
chasing your tail the delta variant may
be getting ahead of you
so this is sort of my plug for go ahead
don't miss an opportunity to do that
rapid test if it's negative you may want
to do a secondary test but you want to
educate the patient you want to explain
to them that that pcr may be more
sensitive it may pick them them up but
there might be a resulting delay
and you can even talk to him a little
bit about the correlation here between
the testing and infectiousness but again
on the side of caution we don't want to
let this spread
what about that test the person comes in
it's a screening program
they have no symptoms they have no
exposure they don't understand what that
means so let's talk a little bit about
understanding the test results
and this is this whole concept about
predictive values to this test and we've
bounced in and out here
you know early on in the pandemic
everyone was positive and we had 40 50
60
um test positivity rates here in new
york um we we really missed this until
it was really prevalent in our community
there a positive test was a positive
test but then
in june early in the summer we actually
got to the point where here in new york
the disease prevalence was actually less
than one percent and we actually were
running into the issue and it doesn't
matter what test you're doing
the specificity is pretty similar for or
whether you talk about antigen or pcr
but people would test positive and the
majority of times that was a false
positive so i just want to point out
here this is really critical your
disease prevalence is going to impact
whether or not that positive you get is
false
or
really reliable once you get above five
percent then yeah your false positive
rate is going to drop down less than 20.
once you get where unfortunately a lot
of us are now 10 or more in a lot of
regions um you're you're looking at
again
that positive predictive value being 90
or higher
but this is critical this is also the
concept where often if we really need to
know um we might do orthogonal right we
might do another test to sort out what's
going on
so i want people to think about that a
lot of settings they'll say that's great
now you feel like you know what's going
on but we're still going to treat a
positive as a positive so
this is science this is what we
understand um you know bureaucracies
departments of health political
decisions
may err on the side of caution
all right well you want to decide which
test am i going to do
hopefully i've given a lot of
information here about what tests you
want to do at the point of care i've
touched a little on what tests you might
want to do as far as screening programs
but but i also want to introduce some
resources here
that might help you
calculate what is the correct test in a
larger screener screening setting so
we've actually gone ahead we created
this as a public service thing it's free
access we posted it on
parasiteswithoutborders.com
basically this testing simulator which
allows you to go in i'm going to click
to the link that you will get
and this is really a simulator that
allows you to try a bunch of different
options say well should i try antigen
test should we do the pcrs what's the
cost benefit how many people am i going
to am i going to pick up
and at what expense to the management so
just a couple scenarios i'm going to run
through
this is the i want the gold standard i
want to do everyone getting a pcr test
you can choose which test you want
you can choose the timeline of how long
you're going to be doing this you can
look at the population that you're going
to focus on
how often am i going to do this am i
going to do this like every other day
you're going to end up with quite a bill
your cost per person in this scenario
is going to be 5 000 dollars
per person for this 100 days and oh my
gosh we're testing a thousand people
that's going to be 5 million right
that's a lot we are going to end up with
37 infections
experienced over this period of time
now what if you say that dr griffin i
don't have five million dollars let's
look at other options i initially wanted
to do a pcr test every other day
you telling me in the movie industry
they're doing one every day well what
about a different scenario where we say
well why don't we do an antigen test
let's do that antigen test every four
days for a thousand people for this
period of time
you can actually go ahead and look at
the number of infections you can look at
the cost per day
so it really this is really a way for
you to go and uh try a bunch of
different things am i going to do
confirmatory testing yes or no
go back to the other one most of the
time we do that right because the
unnecessary quarantines not something
that people really want to do if you say
no on confirmatory testing your
quarantines are going to go up so this
is a tool that you can go after this
and play around with
all right well i want to bring people
back because as i said this is something
i want to burn into people's memory
again
think about the question you're asking
do i really need to catch people in this
window which now i'm going to suggest is
a matter of hours less than a day do i
need to try in a screen program jump in
with pcr
this can be a very expensive way to
catch this
few hours here
if you're looking at people who have
more than an infectious level
for the period of time to say two days
before
three days after onset of symptoms
the antigen tests are going to very
rapidly catch those people but there
will be people that have negative
antigen tests
well a little bit here up front
but more so
after five days after that infectious
window has started to go down
you still want to know in those
individuals in certain settings do they
have covit is this shortness of breath
is this fever
is this requirement for oxygen
due to covet
those people you're going to want that
pcr you're going to want a test that's
going to pick up low levels of virus
that's going to in a sense tell you what
happened
a week ago five days ago
but think about the fact that the
antigen test can be negative in those
settings
talk to those people the same about even
if that
rapid test is negative
if your suspicion is high you're still
going to be talking about isolation from
the infected
they're still going to be starting to
have conversations
about who may have been exposed
you really want to talk to them about
what not to do in the next few days not
to expand that pool of those who are
exposed
all right well let me close with some
resources um as i mentioned
if you want to know more
you can go to
parasiteswithoutborders.com
we actually have a link to that free
calculator to help you if you're making
questions or trying to weigh in on
school screening programs on business
screen programs this is a free tool go
ahead use it play around with it
also what we do is every week we post
what we think are important articles you
want to keep up to date you want to see
the articles not just the press releases
not just the
media take
and we try to keep you up to date on
that
also micro tv we put out a podcast twice
a week actually
one is a deep dive if you want to spend
two hours listening to people like shane
crotty
anthony fauci give you kind of a deep in
depth into what's going on
or once a week we put out a
shorter
more focused clinical update
any changes that clinicians might want
to know about um and then the other um
i'm i hope there are certain questions
that come my way um in the next 15
minutes but in the future if you want to
reach out to me if you have questions
you can send them to info parasites
without borders dot com and then i will
give you a link to my
personal email
and
look forward to questions and hopefully
this has been helpful
extremely helpful thank you so much dr
griffin for that wonderful presentation
and for important research
and now to our audience we will now
start the live q a portion of our
webinar and if you have any questions
please do so now just use that ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen so let's get started
we already have some great questions
coming in from our audience members
our first question dr griffin what data
do you have to say with certainty that
only ct 24 or lower
are infectious and the second part of
that how do you ensure performance when
there is so much variability in sample
collection test performance ct value
differences
yeah so these these are great oh these
are great questions um so there's a
couple things i'll talk about and i'm
going to start first on the um on the
procurement because right that that is
an issue you know who's doing the test
and i think that there was a bias going
into this right that that only we the
skilled clinicians could get that really
that that sample we need we need that
middle turbinate it needs to be in there
the person needs to be crying otherwise
you know you haven't done it
and i think it was really reassuring
when we saw the recent data on the um
the home the buy next now these are
people doing it at home
you know they're they're reading this
this instruction manual they're swabbing
the anterior nares
they're sticking it into the card and
we're getting you know 98 sensitivity
in that what we think is the infectious
period of time we had a we had a nice
study early on we actually was run by
one of the optum groups everett clinic
up in washington where we asked that
question do you really need to get that
sample where you're in the middle
turbinate can you just do that anterior
nares and across hundreds of samples in
a real world situation with
drive-through testing
it's really about two-cycle difference
between that middle turbinate that the
medical professional is gathering and
that that person swabbing their anterior
nares um so yeah are you going to miss a
few percent yes but we have reassuring
data um based upon the different sites
we have reassuring data based upon
people doing it but what about machine
variability i mean that's great doctor
if we have to sample but these machines
um you know you're comparing one machine
to another machine
the the thing here is really again
you're only seeing one or two cycle
variability so early on
there was a lot of concern we got to run
those machines out to 40 or more cycles
because we're going to miss people um
yeah we're we are going to miss people
um but very few you're going to miss
people
maybe a few right there at the front
during that narrow window
when there's very little
viral rna to amplify maybe you're going
to miss a few people at that tail end
after they've passed through that period
of time where they now only have
hundreds
of rna copy numbers so we're reassured
at the procurement stage were reassured
at the machine stage what about those
numbers that's a wonderful chart to have
published but but is it true
and i think again this is the the test
of time there are two things that really
correlate with infectiousness it's
timing and levels of rna
and so that two days two days prior now
a lot of contact tracers extend it to
four right we wanna i don't wanna miss
folks um and we also even though the
majority of infections are being
transmitted
only about three to four days after we
also extend that out to 10 in some areas
longer
that is a time when if you look at our
contact tracing
that's when transmission is occurring if
you look at our viral culture data
that's where you're seeing it as well um
yeah how reliable is the 24 as a number
some people use a slightly higher number
i think anthony fauci has used 30
but yeah you're you're sort of in the in
the realm there the the higher you use
that cutoff right you increase your
sensitivity the lower you use it um
that's going to adjust as well but i
think those are reasonable numbers but
even more important than numbers is the
timing even if you have a ct value
but you're 10 days out
you're probably picking up a lot of rna
you're not picking up viable infectious
virus at that point
thank you so much dr griffin our next
question
and i want to thank our audience these
are great questions come in i've had
several experiences where the rapid test
was negative and then i have to call the
patient with the pcr test comes back
positive
i have decided to stop doing the rapid
test does this make sense
okay
yeah so this this comes up a lot right
and i i was on i was on the brian lair
show that's this npr new york talk show
and you know and the person called in
and it reminded me of these
conversations that i've had with with
urgent care doctors say dr griffin i'm
just you know that happened too many
times my partners are upset with me
because i i listened to you i did the
rapid test and now that rapid test said
they were negative but they really were
positive
and i want everyone to think about those
kinetics right so so the woman calls in
and she says you know i was exposed on
on saturday night so i went ahead and i
spent my hard earned money and i got a
bunch of these at home buy next now
there was a sale it was 20 per two tests
so i did a test on um on sunday morning
i did a test on monday morning i did a
test on tuesday morning you know they're
they're they're still negative and so
but then friday i started to not feel
well so i went and they did
they sent off a pcr test and then they
called me on on sunday to say the pcr
test was positive so why did i waste all
that money
so couple things there right again
remember timing those tests are going to
be negative up front
those rapid tests are going to be
negative on the tail end
the correlation with pcr is during that
infectious period of time so what i tell
people is go ahead do those antigen
tests because they're going to allow you
to very rapidly pick up that person
who's positive pull them out of
circulation
but you may be jumping in like for
instance this person with her exposure
if she had done antigens every day there
was going to be a certain day when the
pcr came up positive and the antigen
wouldn't turn positive until the next
day
and then the same thing is going to
happen on the tail end right that
antigen test is only going to stay
positive for that sort of seven day
window and then it's going to turn
negative and the pcr test so so think
about what tests and what you don't want
to do what you don't want to have on you
is that phone call i talked about when
you call them they're at the office
they're in front of a group of children
and you're calling them to tell them the
pcr test is positive when you could have
rapidly made that diagnosis with an
antigen test but yes if you do antigen
tests and pcrs you will certainly have
periods of time you'll certainly have
multiple anecdotes where that antigen
test was negative and now you're calling
someone about the positive pcr so
educate the patient up front talk to
your partners
make sure everyone understands
the time and the place for the different
tests
absolutely thank you so much and this
next question is related as well
why do a rapid test when a pcr test is a
better test
yeah i mean there is this perception
that you know that the pcr is you know
is the first class you know i don't want
that antigen test you know it's
inexpensive it's rapid i want the pcr um
and the media really i think has done a
lot to create this perception um i think
the perception is evolving again it's
the resulting delay
there's no reason not to do the pcr
if the antigen test is is negative
if the antigen test is positive i'm not
sure you need to do that pcr you
certainly can do it as well but really i
hope the takeaway message is don't don't
fail to make that rapid diagnosis
because particularly as we start to
surge
the pcr
resulting delays are going to really
allow the delta
vary to spread faster than our our
testing
thank you so much and again thank you to
our audience dr griffin was time for one
more question should we be testing
asymptomatic vaccinated
people yeah so this is a great it's a
great question um and a lot of people
you know the data's sort of being sorted
out here um and i think that interesting
was the the providence um experience
that a lot of people talked about where
we now know
that vaccinated people can get infected
um we we do and this is in the province
we know from other experiences and
studies that vaccinated people can
probably for a narrower window transmit
so yeah there certainly are
circumstances um
let's say you know you have a 85 year
old mother and she's on puma and you're
going to go visit her
you might want to add an antigen test
the morning that you go visit them have
that extra layer there definitely are
situations remember the antigen test
sensitivity relates to how much viral
antigen how much nuclear caps it is
there um whether you're symptomatic or
asymptomatic doesn't actually matter
what matters is how much of the material
is there that you can detect so an
asymptomatic vaccinated person who might
be in a setting where a transmission
would be a problem
right there's never miss an opportunity
to test it's worthwhile throwing that
extra layer of protection
thank you so much dr griffin actually we
have time for one more question that
just came in from our chat area
um the audience member says do you see
more thrombotic complications in covid
patients with factor v leading or pros
robin
g2o2 what is that
g2021oa is that what it is factor
two mutations i apologize to the
audience if i didn't say it correctly
it's right there in our presenter chat
um
yeah so no problem so factor five leiden
um it's usually deficiency right that
people are talking about um or the
factor two mutations um and then birth
control right so you're throwing them
you've thrown them all in there so a
couple things that we'll clearly say i
think this is really important so one of
my other hats is i i'm the one
infectious disease physician on the
american society of hematology
anticoagulation guideline committee for
covet
so what are our recommendations what are
they based on
clearly people who are hospitalized with
covid have a higher risk of
complications than the than the general
population do we have enough data to
hone down on individuals like this
not really so we're really extrapolating
from other experience so a person who
comes in with um we'll say a factor five
liden deficiency someone who comes in
with a um with another one of these say
hematological abnormalities so a factor
two mutation
we're going to be making a decision
about the hospitalized setting do we put
them on full anticoagulation
probably if they're in the icu then
there's going to be a risk balance here
you put them on full dose
anticoagulation you may decrease the
risk of clotting but you're going to
increase the risk of bleeding so
we say the preponderance of evidence
favors prophylactic in that setting but
what about outpatients what about a
person shows up or they get a diagnosis
of covid should they start taking an
aspirin if they have these should they
be on anticoagulation
i will say to date
we don't recommend that
the biggest thing is to continue to stay
active we think there's a lot about the
severity of requiring hospitalization
the other medications the immobility in
that setting so no excellent questions
birth control meds yeah i mean i think
this really came to light
when people started talking about the
risk of um with the j and j vaccine in
young women of clotting complications
the vaccine-induced
thrombocytopenic thrombosis and people
said you know what we're talking about
one in a hundred thousand maybe even
more rare than that that's higher than
what we see with birth control pills um
so yeah there is potentially an additive
issue here if you have a young woman um
well any woman up to the point that
they're on birth control pills and they
end up in the hospital with covid now
you're sort of adding multiple factors
that can contribute to risk of venous as
well as arterial thrombotic
complications
dr griffin thank you again for your time
for you for this presentation really
great and very helpful would you like to
provide any closing remarks to our
audience before we go
uh well thank you everyone for taking
the time to attend i like to say never
miss an opportunity to test
never miss an opportunity to rapidly
identify someone who has
who has covet and as we've learned over
time cove is a viral disease it can
present in so many different ways
the only way to really know if someone
has coveted or not is with a covid test
with the sars cov2 test
dr griffin thank you again for your time
and for your for this presentation
and i just want to also thank our
audience for joining us today and for
other interesting questions and
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration and
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
up to two years until september 9 2023
so elaborates will alert you via the
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone and be safe bye